la parole comme monsieur dominique de
meyer merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre et concerne l'emploi
vous avez annoncé la semaine dernière
une baisse du chômage de 0 7% toutes
catégories confondues pour le mois de
septembre nous nous en réjouissons
je devrais dire nous pourrions nous en
réjouir mais en vérité nous sommes très
inquiets nous sommes inquiets car cette
baisse est consécutive à la très forte
hausse du mois précédent et à
l'application du plan 500000 formation
elle ne confirme en aucune façon une
tendance puisque sur un an le chômage
des catégories à b et c est en hausse
nous sommes d'autant plus inquiets car
au crépuscule de ce quinquennat
le bilan en matière d'emploi est
catastrophique
plus d'un million un million deux cent
mille chômeurs supplémentaires depuis
mai 2012
votre politique de lutte contre le
chômage s'est résumée à une politique
d'incantations de colmatage entre
formations supplémentaires et emplois
d'avenir auxquels la ministre du travail
vient de mettre un terme
comme pour acter votre échec cela a
d'ailleurs été confirmée récemment par
la cour des comptes
la réalité c'est que cette politique
n'offre toujours pas de perspectives de
baisse du chômage à long terme
nous sommes inquiets car au fond la
vérité c'est qu aucune réforme de
structure n'aura été menée durant ce
quinquennat
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage est
un mensonge d'état que le président de
la république a brandi comme un étendard
alors que les français attendaient
attendent toujours des actes et des
résultats
après quatre ans de pouvoir quatre ans
et demi de pouvoir alors que la majorité
est fissuré au moment où vous semblez
penser qu'on ne peut pas tout dire allez
vous monsieur le premier ministre
prendre vos distances avec ce triste
bilan et que comptez vous faire pour que
ces cinq derniers mois ne soit pas des
mois perdus pour la france merci la
parole et à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
dominique le ménach la semaine dernière
en effe pôle emploi dans le cas des
chiffres a montré une petite des
demandeurs d'emploi en catégorie à 2,66
300 demandeurs d'emploi c'est une bonne
nouvelle une bonne nouvelle pour les
françaises et les français
une bonne nouvelle pour notre économie
bien évidemment vous faites dans le
cadre de votre question à l'instant vous
parlez de manipulations statistiques ou
voire de mensonges d'état permettez moi
d'y répondre précisément le sénat votre
groupe politique a mis en place une
commission d' enquête sur les chiffres
de pôle emploi que vous semblez
aujourd'hui mettre en doute
alors même permettez moi de les citer il
apparaît que le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi inscrits sur les listes de pôle
emploi ne puisse pas faire l'objet de
soupçons de manipulation ceci est
parfaitement clair et c'est abordé par
une commission d' enquête demandée par
vos groupes politiques
et voilà qu'elle est la conclusion par
ailleurs vous semblez dire ici que le
plan cinq cent mille actions de
formation supplémentaires alors même que
ici dans cet hémicycle nombre d'entre
vous nous ont toujours dit que la france
avait un retard extrêmement important en
matière de formation et demandeurs
d'emploi
cc les doubles discours cesser les
doubles discours à savoir des exécutifs
régionaux qui sont partenaires avec nous
avec les partenaires sociaux pour vous
mettre en oeuvre ce plan
cinq cent mille actions de formation
supplémentaires et ce discours ici
s'agissant de la catégorie des nous le
montrons il n'y a eu aucune hausse de la
catégorie des puisqu'il ya eu autant
d'entrées que de sorties les demandeurs
d'emploi qui passe en formation ne
disparaissent pas des chiffres de pôle
emploi
ils sont en catégorie d et celle ci est
stable s'agissant de ce mois ci enfin
vous semblez partie parler de la
catégorie c la même mission d' enquête
il avait eu justement l'attention de la
lyre vous aurait permis de montrer que
cinq cent mille demandeurs d'emploi
inscrits en catégorie c sont à temps
plein parce qu'ils sont à la recherche
d'un autre emploi
voilà quelle est la réalité donc ne vous
en déplaise le chômage en milieu de nuit
la parole est à mme adam